all right we're going to begin with a
growing debate over how to stop what
president biden is calling the beginning
of a russian invasion of ukraine take a
look at this new satellite imagery from
yesterday it shows russian military
vehicles and tents at an airfield in
belarus there are also fresh reports of
russian vehicles over the border in the
breakaway parts of eastern ukraine
president biden has hit russia with new
sanctions and other nations have joined
in as well to prevent more conflict they
hope mr biden says there could be even
harsher sanctions if russia fails to
stop its aggression
we have a team of correspondents
covering the crisis but we're going to
begin with nancy cordes at the white
house for us nancy good morning
president biden calling this the first
tranche of sanctions
that's right tony and the tension
between this white house and russia is
growing late yesterday secretary of
state anthony blinken called off a
planned meeting with russia's foreign
minister he said it doesn't make sense
at this point to go ahead with talks now
that the invasion has begun
this is a flagrant violation of
international law
president biden responded to russia's
invasion with what he called the first
tranche of financial penalties imposing
sanctions on two large russian banks
with ties to the russian military
cutting them off from western investment
ukraine's foreign minister hailed the
news hit
russia's economy
now
and hit it hard but some lawmakers from
both parties are pushing the president
to unleash all the economic punishments
he's prepared i think you should use the
overwhelming amount of it now impose
the toughest
possible
sanctions the toughest possible
sanctions now the white house is
coordinating with allies who also impose
new sanctions germany put a hold on the
nordstream 2 pipeline a top putin
project that would carry natural gas
from russia to europe president biden is
also moving some u.s troops already
based in europe to the baltic states in
an effort to support nato allies that
border russia to the west let me be
clear
these are totally defensive moves on our
part
we have no intention of fighting russia
secretary of state anthony blinken said
talks with his russian counterpart are
off until russian aggression abates we
will not allow russia to claim the
pretense of diplomacy
at the same time it accelerates its
march down the path of conflict and war
starting today the u.s is also going to
be imposing sanctions on specific
russian oligarchs and the u.k is taking
similar steps but ukraine's foreign
minister wants the u.s to go even
further he says that putin and his inner
circle should be targeted with sanctions
too in a tweet he said hit more hit hard
hit now
nate
nancy thank you